penso a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
avessero sono passato nel menu cazzo
vabbè bella più che ragazzi ebbene vede
che sono video sono fa vj ci siamo dati
su torba dismount che era da secoli che
non lo facevo ma adesso ho scoperto che
ci sono io nel menu e quindi l'ho fatto
i ragazzi aperto tutto trovato ci sono
un gruppo di tipo questo dovevo farlo
siccome ne avevo fatti di merda l'ultima
volta mi ha detto fare ma fai un livello
dove ti va è una parola cazzo prova a
fare fragalà ragazzi l'ultima volta che
ho fatto sta roba che cosa cazzo è
questo il bello bellissimo vecchio a
testa tipo
[Musica]
i ragazzi a parte il pupazzo figo ma
figo è veramente dir poco ma c'è anche
alla madonna c'è chi cazzo è stato io io
io ti voglio sposare adesso bertola il
sudore la sella pulita amico mio
i ragazzi e per questo problema cosa ci
sono altri pupazzi altre cose tipo
pupazzi a essi sono al modo il coso
adesso è molto più sexy ragazze io mio
santo non ho mai pensato di essere così
figo come ballerino a parte sta roba
sono già morto laws venuto a grazie
grazie mille molto gentile io non vorrei
di ragazzi però se vedete nel caso un fa
vige in autostrada
così sapete che sono io che ok è un
bordello a lucignolo non ce la fa
romagna mente chiesto tutti di rifare
questo livello di riuscirci ma è
impossibile regala cazzo se non prendevo
il gradino era fattibile buongiorno
grazie era la mia la macchina comunque
era trova veramente ragazzi ma certe
cose non le capisco se kyosanto c'era
una macchina sola ce n'era grazie vince
almeno per me amica mia cosa succede
addio
se la stanno stuprando in 26 va bene è
stato bello tanto soprattutto tu che sei
finito in groppa a un altro complimenti
voi non lo sapete lega perché non vedete
il video intero ma finire un livello di
turbo dismount impossibile allora
proviamo a fare una roba dio santo cosa
demos lander mai mai mai mai mai mai mai
mai bye bye bye bye bye bye bye 66 ma
edizione nota ci ha fatto già faccio no
[ __ ] di merda misto non c'era
l'ultimo ce l'ho fatta porca l'appunto
landia questa bellissima ragazzi sembra
tipo è in arrivo c'è vento giusto farla
tipo uguale
non lo so se ci somiglia ma va bene cosi
triciclo si è ovvio voi anche la crema
solare zio cioè fammi capire che cazzo è
sta roba
ma sei serio non è tranquillo lui c'è
una roma grazie una macchina c'era ed è
così che io vado in moto baby e andavo
in moto così grazie del passaggio molto
gentile ma io voglio che sono notare
sculettamento mentre parto move your
fucking buri sexy
new york a parte il fatto che gli sta
posizione sono uguale identico smigol ma
a parte quello perché sembra che stia
cagando su questa cosa va beh non
importa ragazzi forse così sono
leggermente più possente riesco a
demolire le macchine che ecco è una
madonna che volo ha fatto bravo bravo
bravo bravo un pene bravo non c'è niente
basta ragazzini saluti [ __ ] basta
basta barry gaura ha già mi chiami al
suo di corato adesso cioè io vorrei che
allora va bene la pigrizia giuro gergo
capisco ma cazzo troppo lucrezia poi
stessa bravo titoli dai cazzo gradi
madonna in un carro armato so cosa farò
il prossimo
sono morti tutti va bene e stato bello
ho vinto ho fatto un disastro epocale
tipo fantastico number one questo
ragazzi ce l'ho fatta subito
qua non potete dire niente it del fen ma
l'ho mai fatto o dio che è cosa troppo
figo ragazzo questa roba non l'ho mai
fatto in vita mia e nuovo richiamo
personaggio che cazzo mi mette l'ansia
questo ok mister ego mister ego fare
morto
mica sono morto è bello si va i ragazzi
e ci siamo fedeli pronti per la vittoria
incredibile un cazzo cazzo sto guidando
bello adesso forse un po lento morto
mentre che annuncia farò mai nella vita
beccare le mine in volo impossibile sì
sì sì ce lo fa e basta
la parte sbagliata ma è già qualcosa che
tuffo che tuffo sexy prova la massima
velocità una volta vedere che cazzo di
fine faccio mai vai così vai così la
morte nera mamma mi piace botta per far
fuori campo ragazzi fuori che ho vinto
tutto io visto che è successo infatti
punti ho fatto mi piace casinò la
meraviglia ma posso anche invitare io
cazzo ma dite loro sas o sapevo prima
cos'è sta roba mio dio che acrobazia a
cazzo è morto e defunto proprio mio dio
voglio replay vista roba non fatevi
vedere replay assolutamente st parte non
l'ho vista bene fatemi vedere un attimo
mi piace può trama dato bellissimo che
presenterà la mia testa è partita in
quarta su 21.10 per fa vijay vetro
parole post lane questo dove c'era la
mia faccia prima ed ai ragazzi questo è
impossibile come faccio a farla
decentemente cioè l'ultima volta ci
avevo messo gli anni per riuscito a fare
un giro davvero sopravvivere un giro in
giro
ge niente un cazzo sono morto subito
bello grazie grazie molto gentile oddio
è diventata una molto futuristica cioè
ragazzi stava sta roba è veloce si
sculaccia amenta bellissima
[Musica]
ragazzi credo di aver trovato il
parrucchiere son convinto bellissimo
presso non fumo e vabbè ho i capelli
tagliati sicuro che non me l'ha
investito lo skate non me li investono
come non detto cazzo ci per un attimo ci
ho creduto almeno scritti si poteva
salvare
dove sono io di precisa molto bello
almeno lo skate è intatto almeno solo
questo ragazzo ho scoperto adesso che
posso guidare io basta la mia vita è
finita poi così guido io guida favi
bastardi cazzo perché io so guidare
fermo che mi investe non mi sono mi
riesco anche a questo
oddio mi soprende si guarda ecco la
bellissima strike ragazzi di un bordello
sto cazzo di gioco perché no no non puoi
scivola no
calata la [ __ ] la [ __ ] la
conosci la [ __ ] faccio conosce
guarda che merda ma perché posso ancora
guidare volendo bello ti dava fastidio
il mio cofano zio se io mi cambia il
tipo me ne metto un obeso ecco vede come
cazzo cade l'obeso mortacci so cosa stai
facendo favicon stai facendo
basta mi sono rotto le palle costo
livello inutile cambiamo allora il
inserito proprio questa ragazza e da un
secolo che non faccio quello del treno
incidenti in treno eccolo qui voglio che
ci vai con la cosa giusta mi come
esattore
[Musica]
pagherei reni orgoglioso lo zio fa
virendi l'orgoglioso cazzo prendi
l'orgoglioso cazzo proprio almeno
stavolta va beh quasi quasi in pieno
però mi accontento non ci si accontenta
nella vita che bella faccia che ciò
tanto non ho mai visto un bambino così
se mi son cagato addosso fantastico e mi
sa che mi sono pagato di nuovo addosso
madonna ufficiale sembra che sta
guidando mia nonna no e vabbè ho l come
cazzo fai da te c'è mi sembrava troppo
strano come mai possibile che una sedia
da ufficio a rotelle si va beh no no no
no di quello modo suisse bank sa cos'è
sta roba che non ho visto l'ultima volta
fatevi provare non ho capito cosa stai
facendo favi che cazzo fai va bene che
sei [ __ ] però date un contegno mio dio
si può fare un livello del gemello
complimenti fuori alla follia la mappa
diritto non sono caduto perché c'era la
protezione questo è vero significato di
dare il culo in autostrada ragazzi e
questo mi sa che è affacciata bellissima
facciata incrementato mi è rimasto il
manubrio in mano perche sto tremando
ma perchè queste ragazze la sculettata
spiegatemi il senso di certe cose ha poi
fatto che io non ho ancora capito sto
livello qui dove dovrei arrivare
protesti decisio cos'è sta roba già mi
chiami storico ma l'aspetti di
sculettare mi dà fastidio sto riprovando
a fare gli stessi livelli dell'altra
volta solo che non ha capito che io non
capisco qual è lo scopo di livelli per
me sono fatti tutti no cubi adesso
questa mela 2
ok perfetto replay tutta la vita ragazzi
di questa cosa non l'ho capito terminati
fermi inattiva ragazzi ho fatto la cosa
più epica della storia un secondo prima
e poi c'è allora sono passati sotto un
pullman senza farmi colpire impossibile
e poi sono riusciti a colpirmi di soft
impossibile si è ovvio 9 terminati
voglio vedere dove arriva voglio solo
capire dove arrivare al premio eco ma ci
avrei pensato duras anche di meno
sinceramente ma perfetto perfetto zio
hai capito tutto dalla vita
se riesco a fare il suo livello al
contrario voglio un nobel bellissimo il
manubrio cielo però quando finisco di
fare sto cazzo di video voglio capire
dalla vita che cosa ho concluso perché
non bene faccio questo e poi basta
perché ce la faccia ce la faccio supera
lo cazzo dai che serve un forte e
muscoloso sta merda sei muscle bravo
bravo bella zio è così ma cos'è sta roba
[Musica]
amico mio sei l'idolo delle folle cioè
fa devo dire non c'è il collo non ha un
buco della gola prima è rimasto lì dove
lui si è cagato addosso all'inizio
perfetto ho vinto bello essa è stato
istruttivo comunque ragazzi faccio
l'ultimo che big air congo faccio questo
è l'ultimo che non sono mai riuscito ad
arrivare alla fine poi basta perché sono
tipo
questa è la risposta no no no mi chiami
6 smontato tutto il parabrezza bello
complimenti ragazzi autodemolizione fa
vj lo apro domanda si macchia cela un
fatto non chiedetevi come ma ho vinto
dato sono finito dentro il parabrezza
va bene comunque ragazzi con curve
episodio perché è stato tra veramente io
ho bisogno di aria fresca in questo
momento che il mio cervello non può più
sopportare certe cose turche ragazzi che
ho incluso quell'episodio spero che vi
sia piaciuto non ne posso più di turbo
this month me lo sogno anche la notte il
mio ciuffo è d'accordo e quindi ragazzi
il servizio è piaciuto la7 lasciato
commento mi piace anche a pagine
facebook e come noi video tra
transizione scorse ore si di schemi e ci
vediamo un prossimo video lancia no
lancia lancia meglio cazzo beh ragazzi